i think livestream is a [ __ ]
psychopath i don't know
they have to be like because you have
that beautiful
thing of like when when you have the
hollow life it's doing the work for you
yeah you just gotta put the voice which
is easy
i say that as a youtube creator with
total [ __ ] respect
that i have no idea how you guys [ __ ]
do that
oh yeah it's insane i don't know how
because i two hours of streaming and i
start to like lose my energy yeah yeah
yeah how tall i won't
be screaming for 12 hours i don't know i
don't get it like after i'm like
streaming for two hours two hours is
like my limit
anything off past two hours i'm like
pushing i'm like running on empty
yeah i i i whenever i stream i press
like the end stream button and i go on
my couch and i collapse
after two it is it's really [ __ ]
tiring and
you know we have we all have friends
that can do [ __ ] you know eight nine
hour streams daily and i'm just like how
how do you do that [ __ ] i [ __ ] left
my stream on the other day when i
thought i turned it off
really oh really i i left my house and
then some people were tweeting me like
dude yo your stream's still on bro
i'm like what i checked and it was just
on
and then i looked at like the final 10
minutes before i left yeah
and like i go like bye guys
you can guys go and see this i don't
know what the hey at least you didn't
like jack off on stream
all right get the head out could you
imagine if i was just like
done n-wood
like that's just my thing when i'm done
you know what i'm standing up and this
is the dick's just flopping out
god i just hate that group of people
like history man
okay tyler one become a v tuber dude
just i'm saying it that would be [ __ ]
insane
we need a v with the screams like tyler
warm bro i mean i don't know there's a
lot of [ __ ] japanese
obviously you obviously have not seen
some of youtubers that [ __ ] blow off
your ears oh my god but then it's three
dude it's the muscles combined with it
that just add to the character building
that's the real i think
i
i don't know okay and as well like i
think there's a
i don't know if this is just me right
but it's the reason why i can't
like enjoy certain things and okay i
want to make this very clear before
people get angry at me because i know
people do
because i'm like connor doesn't like all
the live kind of hates all this stuff i
don't
i just i'm interested in in other
aspects and i
think blindly just being like yeah i
[ __ ] love this thing it's like
[ __ ] boring
we won't have a discussion here yeah of
course i it's a japanese company right
hall alive yeah let's be honest yeah i'm
really curious about that cut
i want to know what it is because i want
to know what that contract is like
because i
i guarantee that it is it is it is
skewed
towards the gym oh yeah it's probably
like machinima quality right i'm betting
into machinima
yeah we're talking like i would be
genuinely surprised if they're getting
if the creator is getting 30
or or more if they were getting more
than 20
i would probably call [ __ ] right i
think they're getting anywhere between
20 and 10
again this is just speculation like i
just know that's
a very big possibility because you've
been approached by a japanese youtube
agency before right
many times yeah and they were offering
similar cards right absolutely garbage
like what was the lowest one you've
received the lowest one i received was
uh
70 30 but 70 to the company 30. yeah
that's how it is but you were already
established at that point which is
disgusting yeah
right it's ridiculous i think i had like
almost 2 million subs it was it was not
that long ago sometime last year it's
really rare for an a
especially if you're an established
talent yeah right so this is the kind of
numbers that you were probably getting
pitched by japanese company who realized
that you were established yeah
can you imagine when you're not
established yeah like
what numbers they're going to be
pitching you all right and i know i norm
likes to do that right because it's like
what
you focus on the character the
entertainer they're having fun they like
it and it's like
when you're new you don't know what
what's good yeah
like you know i've spoken to many
youtubers who
i have personally like helped with deals
who were they were getting paid
like one thousand dollars for like
sponsorships oh yeah yeah
ten times that right yeah just because
they're happy with the deal doesn't make
it okay
yeah i'm sure like oh no absolutely yeah
like i i wonder
if like again it could be a totally fair
deal i don't know i'm just
i would like to know just because i
makes me worry well
i guess this goes into like just the
darker side of idol
industry period because it's not only a
japanese company
it's a japanese idol company yeah and we
know that
that's good and i i can i'm interested
to see
we'll never find out but i would love to
know the rules that they're under
well i i i don't know because i feel
like
with i'd like to think it's modern yeah
i i would also like to think it's modern
you know it's a japanese camera
yeah so on the other hand i mean there's
this is all speculation so none of us
know what
you know what kind of deal the talent
has going on i could be completely
[ __ ] wrong and yeah like a complete
kind of because
i totally i i i'll fully apologize for
that if i am but yeah
i'm just going off based off of
experience no you're just you're just
playing devil's ad
yeah yeah yeah i i mean get going
yeah because it feels like to me just
just just part of the reason that hollow
live
rose up so much in the beginning was
because compared to
other let's say idle agencies and idle
companies
it's it's like part of it was that they
just kind of let the girls do whatever
the [ __ ] they want with
less restrictions yeah i mean like par
like most idol
companies don't allow girls to [ __ ]
swear or
like tell other girls are gonna piss on
each other which is like one one of like
the holocaust highlights
the reason the reason the whole life
expanded so much in
our community was just how much they
were allowed to shitpost and how much
freedom right yeah yeah but
but but i wonder if there's somebody at
the charge of it who's like all right
let them shitpost and we'll keep the
profit
give us